a pesar del frío las iraníes encuentran
formas creativas de continuar su lucha
por la libertad
en las calles de Teherán el domingo por
la tarde incluso esta pelea con bolas de
nieve es un acto de protesta Estas
mujeres están en la calle y no llevan el
velo en la cabeza por ello podrían
enfrentarse hasta 10 años de cárcel
no me cobró el pelo porque creo que es
lo menos que podemos hacer hemos hecho
algunos cambios positivos solo estamos
al principio siempre me pongo el velo
alrededor del cuello Así que si siento
peligro puedo cubrirme la cabeza porque
temo por mi familia
[Aplausos]
al narrar lo que ocurre sobre el terreno
las iraníes ponen en peligro sus vidas
para hablar con esta activista
utilizamos un sistema especial de
videochat cifrado en el despacho de un
abogado parisino
decidimos cambiar nuestra forma de
protestar la represión ha sido muy
agresiva y ha muerto demasiada gente
hemos transformado los funerales de los
condenados a muerte En plataformas
políticas hemos estado imprimiendo
panfletos y distribuyéndolos por las
calles y si el régimen nos pide que
hagamos algo hacemos Exactamente lo
contrario
los simulacros de juicios y las
ejecuciones no han hecho más que avivar
la ira
no tenemos tiempo para llorar cada vez
que perdemos a alguien cercano nos hace
más fuertes todos estamos atrapados en
esto todos tenemos miedo pero no hay
vuelta atrás creemos que funcionará
sabemos que debemos derrocar al régimen
y llegar hasta el final
está dispuesta a arriesgar su vida ya lo
estoy haciendo
las protestas han ido mucho más allá de
los derechos de la mujer la gente
también está enfadada por la grave
situación económica incluso las mujeres
conservadoras se están levantando
no estoy de acuerdo con las autoridades
Dios no es tan Injusto como para
castigarnos simplemente por llevar un
velo en la cabeza debemos ser libres se
está produciendo un cambio un gran
cambio de mentalidad es una revolución
las autoridades han intensificado su
mortal represión y han culpado a los
manifestantes de la desastrosa situación
económica del país